You know that old saying about the Fox
guarding the hen house.
So I like to tell it for a different
version of that story with the
backstory,
you know,
where the hens,
regular people trying to live our lives
and we had a guard of the hen house.
It's the government wasn't perfect
but it,
but it did a reasonable job of
protecting us from each other of
guarding equality.
Make sure,
making sure none of the hens were
pecking the other hands too much.
And then came along last 30,
40 years,
uh,
Fox and the Fox is big business and
wealthy people and the Fox didn't like
know the guard because the fox kind of
one of the hens to itself,
it was what the Fox do it bit by bit
that garden,
like it argued the government was bad,
government was the enemy had defunded
government at fought for lower taxes so
government could do less stuff.
Then the guard starts stumbling away and
bleeding out
off the scene.
Hens are unguarded and the Fox presents
itself to the hands and says what a
shame.
Government is just not,
not what it used to be.
Not,
not solving and not protecting you,
not fighting for it.
So efficient.
It's so,
gosh,
that's so sad.
Well,
let me step in and,
and,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm rich and I'm here to help.
Well,
rich people and wealthy corporations
spent a generation waging a war on
government,
defunding government,
allowing social problems to fester and
allowing their own profits to soar.
And then with government weekend social
problems multiplying and their own
pockets full,
they reinvent themselves as the new
replacement of government,
which is,
you know,
instead of trickle down economics,
we now have trickled down,
change,
let them make their fortune and you
know,
and then they'll just throw some social
change down from the mountain.
Well,
we have to decide in America,
that's the kind of change we want.
Uh,
but what I do know is if you project
that kind of change backwards throughout
time,
we wouldn't have created most of the
change that we all take for granted
today.
I mean,
if,
uh,
you know,
there,
there would frankly have been no new
deal.
There'd be no modern American economy if
we had depended on the powerful to throw
down scraps.
Many of the most important things in
American life had to be taken from the
powerful and given to the mini.
And it's,
it's time that we reclaim that heritage.
Again,
I think it's hard to understand why
populism is rising throughout the world
without reckoning with the role of a
class of global one percenters who are
remote from their communities,
more connected to each other then to the
communities they live in,
um,
and seemingly devoted to profit and
returns above all else.
The fascinating and complicated thing
about this global populace moment is
that it takes very different forms.
I mean,
here there's a very strong racial
dynamic to it that is at the heart of
it.
Um,
there are other places where that's less
of a factor.
In some places it's about,
you know,
internal racial things and other places
about immigration and some places it's
about all of the above.
But I think what is undeniable in this
country is that for 30 or 40 years,
many people on the left and right have
felt that things were not going right,
that the country wasn't working for
them,
that it felt rig to them,
that it felt impossible to secure the
life that they were promised by this
country.
Um,
and to give their children something
better than they had.
And that all that,
while there was a lot of rich explaining
to those people by the American elite
that no,
no,
things are great trades,
good trades going to not non trade
trade's great cause we perfect.
So we'll lift everybody up.
Globalization.
Perfect.
It's great.
Look there's a couple of bumps but no
worries.
And the in the aggregate all will be
well.
I mean as though anybody lives in the
aggregate,
um,
tech don't,
ah,
don't worry.
Don't worry about that fact that,
you know,
everything got automated in your jobs.
All went to Taiwan.
Don't worry about it.
We'll be better off on the whole.
And there was just a lot of this kind of
rich planning.
I grew up and I remember studying these,
this stuff in college,
when I took economics classes,
like I went to the University of
Michigan,
I was sitting in Michigan and Econ,
econ 101 and I remember getting this
lecture on how all this stuff was for
the good.
As we'd better off and right around us
all around us in Michigan in 1999,
the state was falling apart these long
tectonic shifts where basically like
work was disappearing and trade was not
benefiting most people.
And globalization was not a walk in the
park and aggregate effects.
We're not really have any comfort to
anybody.
And how was it possible at the
University of Michigan in 1999 with all
of that evidence all around us that we
could sit in an intellectual cocoon and
explained to ourselves that,
you know,
rising tides lift all boats essentially.
Um,
there is a way in which American elites,
and this is not just a couple of greedy
hedge fund billionaires,
American,
the American intelligentsia also has
been complicit in a false story about
air,
all things working out for people over
the last generation.
That wasn't true.
And I think people felt that and
revolted against it.
And it's really,
really unfortunate that particularly in
the trump movement,
the someone who actually tapped into
that intuition,
people have,
that elites weren't maybe as sincere and
fighting for them as,
as they claimed that Donald Trump,
instead of seizing on that anger and
channeling at the institutions and
people who had actually done that
instead in this cowardly and sad and
lowly and hateful way,
deflected that anger onto Muslims and
immigrants and women and people of Color
and whatever,
you know,
that's the,
the ultimate and tragic nonsequitor of
American politics today.
People are correctly,
people correctly feel screwed by an
economic order that doesn't have as much
space for regular people to make a life
as it used to.
But they have been led by a phony
billionaire real estate developer to
feel as though those problems were
caused not by Goldman Sachs,
but by black people.
And that is the tragedy of this moment.
And that's why it's going to take
someone on the democratic side who was
actually able to speak to the concerns
of regular people about being shut out.
By the way,
there's more shout out people on the
democratic voter base than the
Republican voter base.
But the Democrats I think have struggled
to speak in the language of people who
feel left out by the future.
Um,
socially,
many of the most prominent Democrats,
it's just they don't know and live among
those people.
You can,
you can have a lot of heart and you can
have a good speech writer.
Um,
but you either live in a world that has
more Goldman Sachs people in it,
or a world that has more union
organizers in it.
It's,
it's,
it's just as your real friends,
as your,
as your real fellow travelers.
And I think people are actually good at
sniffing who's who.
And I think the Democratic Party needs
to get serious about being the party of,
of regular people who feel shut out by
this age and that that must mean not
being the party of Goldman Sachs in any
way.
Mm.